the tough choices facing many americans
trying to safely visit their families
for christmas
millions of people are still traveling
despite cdc warnings about the dangers
of spreading covet 19.
the u.s reported more than 228 thousand
new coronavirus cases just yesterday
many health care workers are sacrificing
their own christmas celebrations to keep
up
a record 119 thousand people
are hospitalized in the u.s this morning
in many cases
isolated from their families as they
fight to survive
icus are already full in some areas and
the worst of the pandemic
may be still to come mola lenghi is
outside mount sinai hospital in new york
city mulla good morning well good
morning jamie you know as you know in so
many ways it's frontline healthcare
workers who have been bearing the brunt
of this pandemic and
you know during the holidays it's no
different if anything and it's a lot in
a lot of cases it's actually worse
especially for those doctors and nurses
who have chosen to stay away from their
families throughout this pandemic
in order to keep them safe all this as
new york city like so many other places
tries to combat yet another threat from
the uk
we're going to have sheriff's deputies
go to the home
or the hotel of every single traveler
coming in
from the uk mayor bill de blasio is
stepping up
quarantine enforcement in new york city
with news of another new strain of
covid19 emerging in the uk
he says all travelers from the uk who
don't quarantine will face a fine of a
thousand dollars
the model predicts that the worst is yet
to come
in southern california the head of la
county's department of health
services says ambulances are waiting an
hour in some places
just to drop off patients predicting
more than 8
000 people will die county-wide in the
coming weeks
no matter how safe you think you or your
loved ones have been that perception
is a false reality covet 19 is
absolutely rampant
in los angeles county on the vaccination
front florida governor ron desantis
signed an executive order wednesday
prioritizing seniors over essential
workers
like teachers or public transit
employees defying the recommendation of
the cdc
people that are 73 74 would be in the
back of the line for for a young 21 year
old worker who's considered quote
essential
that doesn't i think makes sense it's a
move that doesn't sit well with
florida's teachers union
he continues to basically thumb his nose
at educators saying
you're not worthy of being protected and
for those who are getting the vaccine
life is already changing my kids were
just so excited
my wife was you know a little teary-eyed
dr franklin lynn a neurosurgeon with
georgia's wellstar health system got his
vaccination while facetiming his family
living alone since march to protect his
wife and kids he's mostly been
communicating with them virtually
soon he can resume his dad duties at
home what do you miss the most about
about being home i'm excited to put the
kids to bed that was that was always my
original job
although more than a million americans
have already been vaccinated that is
still
about 19 million shy of what the federal
government projected
by the end of this year and it's
unlikely that goal will be achieved
according to the chief
of operation warp speed who says simply
because the process of
putting shots in arms vlad has just
taken much longer than anticipated
indeed it has mullah lanky for us at new
york city mogo thank you very much